what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and we
finally got the first teaser trailer for
venom let there be carnage and we
actually did get a look at carnage
not going to lie i was kind of worried
that they weren't going to show us in
the teaser trailer
but no need to worry because of course
we saw carnage and we'll get to that in
a bit we're going to break this down
shot by shot scene by scene and quick
reminder i'm giving away a marvel legend
stormbreaker all you have to do to enter
subscribe to me and subscribe to my
other channel cosmic culture
link down below so sony does this thing
where they kind of put a
teaser in front of the teaser trailer
they kind of give you a glimpse of
what's to come in the trailer
we'll skip that and just start with the
beginning the trailer takes us back to
california where we join
tom hardy's eddie brock and venom we're
taken back to the same apartment that
eddie brock had from the very first
movie
the first thing that we see is a sign
that says rules
no eating people and this seems to be
written on a pizza box
venom has kind of become notorious for
eating people and just simply wanting to
eat in general which is what we see
during this opening scene here
venom not eddie brock and venom but
venom's personality himself
seems to have grown it looks like he's
grown pretty accustomed to earth as he
is kind of doing things on his own while
eddie brock just sits there and is kind
of annoyed
venom since he can't eat people is
making breakfast out of normal things
although we do see some chickens walking
around inside of the apartment
and these could very well be for venom
to eat later venom is enjoying some
music
as he makes himself some food and he
turns up the volume on an
old sony radio in which of course venom
is a sony property so if there's going
to be a radio it's definitely going to
be a sony brand
however venom doesn't exactly have the
best control over everything so he kind
of makes a mess makes an awful breakfast
and most importantly kind of annoys
eddie brock now in the scene where eddie
is sitting down at the table and venom
asks for ketchup
eddie has something in his hand it's
hard to make out and then it gets
covered in ketchup but this could be
important
it is red so it could symbolize the
carnage symbiote but we'll get back to
that in a bit
eddie goes back to the same grocery
store where they gave us that famous
like a turd in the wind scene from the
first venom film
and he says hi to mrs chen and so does
venom and we actually see venom wave
however what's very interesting is
it doesn't sound like mrs chin actually
hears venom as eddie has to actually
tell her
venom says hi however we do see a
symbiote tentacle reach out of eddie's
back as he says hi
so we can't assume that she sees him but
doesn't hear him
we then cut to cletus cassidy the host
of the carnage symbiote who doesn't
actually have it yet
the last time we saw him was in the
venom post credit scene where he said
when he gets out there will be
carnage now the trailer shows us two
different facilities they show us a
maximum security prison and they also
show us the ravencroft institute for the
criminally insane
and it's probably safe to assume that
cletus cassidy has been
in both of these facilities we cut the
cletus inside of a prison cell where
there are tons of different writings and
carvings in the wall
he's drawn a bunch of different monster
faces some could even be symbiotes
it is possible that he saw venom or
another symbiote on tv from the first
film
we see writings on the wall that say
things like sweet death
and if we look right to the right of
cletus cassidy one carving even looks
like groot and
it looks like he's actually writing
something on a card that looks fairly
similar to the card that eddie was
holding in the first scene in his
apartment now the card had
red lines scribbled all over it which is
obviously reflective and symbolic of
carnage although
he doesn't have the symbiote at this
time but it still has to mean something
that we'll find out during the movie
but it is very apparent that cletus
cassidy did
send this to eddie because in this one
scene where he smashes a spider we can
see this card
very clearly and we can see that cletus
kind of draws all around it
now the next scene is of eddie brock
visiting cletus cassidy in the prison so
that could have been a
letter to eddie stating that he is on
death row he's going to be put to death
soon we hear cletus say
i've been thinking about you eddie
because you and i
are the same every decision we ever make
who do we leave behind and how do we
leave them waiting in the darkness for
the rescuer that never comes
welcome back eddie brock it's been a
long time i missed you
and woody harrelson does a really good
job at sounding very
very creepy and insane and let's just
take a second to acknowledge and
appreciate the fact that that horrible
red wig is gone from the post credit
scene of venom cletus cassidy now has
some
relatively normal red hair but there are
some very important scenes going on here
while cletus is talking to eddie we see
eddie going through some paper
the daily bugle is on his computer in
the background and these papers seem to
be drawings from cletus cassidy
now we obviously know that cletus gets
out of prison so the trailer could be
jumping around different points of time
in the movie so eddie could be going
over these papers and drawings after
cletus already escapes and we can
actually see in the paper that eddie is
holding
a cathedral and this scene is actually
going to be later visited by venom
and presumably carnage we later see
venom jump on top of the cathedral
holding a metal pole now for those of
you who don't know eddie is responsible
for cletus being in jail
he was a mass murderer and it seems very
public that he's about to be put to
death
we see stephen graham's character
holding a newspaper and his character
was unknown to us at the time but it
seems like he's just going to be playing
a detective he could have been on the
cletus cassidy case as he is reading a
newspaper that says
the hidden victims of cletus cassidy and
as he's reading the article it looks
like he's getting very very upset
most likely thinking of all the victims
of cletus cassidy and how he probably
couldn't stop
him before he got to those victims now
when cletus is talking to eddie about
people they've left behind and how they
leave them
they show us the ravencroft institute
and they show us a woman
this woman is most likely francis
barrison aka
shriek shriek had been reported to be in
venom let there be carnage and
considering the way her eye looks i'm
definitely saying this is her
during the maximum carnage storyline
where carnage violently escapes he comes
across shriek who wished to join him so
he freed her and the two of them set out
on a
massive killing spree together now the
trailer implies that there could be some
sort of a connection between
cletus and shriek but it's unsure if
this connection was formed
before they both got into the institute
or in the institute
but more on that in just a second we see
cletus about to be put to death
they're about to inject him with the
poison that kills him or at least
should kill him and speaking of the
victims i was mentioning before
it looks like a lot of their families
are actually watching him be put to
death
however that doesn't exactly work out
for them or for anybody else in this
facility
we can see the poison go into his body
but right before it enters we actually
see some red liquid come out which we
could assume is blood
but i actually believe this is the
carnage symbiote
saving cletus cassidy from the poison
it's unclear at this point how exactly
cletus gets the symbiote but it does
sort of appear like it's already inside
of him and it's reacting to this poison
not so well
and this is probably what causes carnage
to be unleashed
it seems like whatever facility they
were at seems to be destroyed and in the
flames of this destruction we can
actually see
two people walking out and i'm assuming
that this is actually going to be cletus
carnage and francis shriek now they
might have tried to put cletus to death
in a security prison and then he escapes
and goes to the ravencraft institute to
save shriek because judging by the gates
it does seem like what is on fire is the
ravencraft institute and since cletus
was talking about the people that they
left behind it would make sense that he
would go back and get shriek
now in the comics street can generate
sound waves that are super powerful and
she used them as
blasts and we can sort of see that as
she's trapped inside of this cell
screaming and everything is sort of
flying around and then after this we see
the scene where cletus cassidy
via the carnage symbiote is breaking out
of the prison
carnage destroys some police cars he
destroys some helicopters and then we
finally get our first
full look at carnage now we get the
title card and then we get a scene with
eddie brock and mrs chan and she says
that the chocolate shipment hasn't come
in yet and this of course is for venom
he loves chocolate but eddie says we had
a deal and she says what are you going
to stop protecting me so the deal was
clearly
you give me chocolate and i'll protect
you from all the people that come in
here
venom asks to eat mrs chen and eddie
says no you can't eat her but again
she can't hear venom so it only seems
like people can hear venom when the
symbiote has fully taken over eddie
brock
now the very last scene is of carnage at
the cathedral
now the cathedral probably has some
connection to cletus cassidy's past but
it also may go on to become the cult of
null null was an eldritch god of
darkness and he was the creator of the
symbiotes in the cult of null the
members worshiped null
and the symbiotes now i don't think noel
is going to be showing up but perhaps
carnage himself could get some followers
on the cult of knoll or the cult of
carnage could be established but that
was our first
look at the teaser trailer for venom let
there be carnage what did you think
about this specifically did you like
how carnage looked i for one am actually
pretty satisfied with how woody
harrelson
is playing cletus cassidy i think he's
doing a great job and i think the movie
is actually going to be
rather good i do like how carnage looked
but let me know your thoughts down below
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all of the latest
venom let there be carnage news don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me